i want to read you something i wrote
yesterday on facebook i think it was
sunday night
i would love for you to touch on i want
to read this to you because i got a lot
of people that told me they said pat you
know
i'm disappointed in you talking politics
you should stick to business you should
stick to this and you shouldn't talk
about politics
so at 11 30 at night i said listen i'm
just going to post this and here's what
i wrote i'm about to disappoint many of
you
i've been getting a few messages lately
from some fans saying to stick to
business videos and avoid discussing
politics
i want to clarify your relationship in
this post there are
many different types of people who
follow my content those who found me
five years ago from watching life of an
entrepreneur in 90 seconds those who
watch all the business sales and
entrepreneurial content i put up
those who watch me break the different
topics on the board u.s china trade war
brexit venezuela history of ufc are on
conflict minimum wage a lot of different
videos
those who watch the bodybuilding
interviews those who watch the mob
interviews those who watch motivation
monday those who read your next five
moves
those who attended the vault those who
accidentally followed me because of
someone recommending it those who
currently
work with me or used to work in the past
with me in the past
those who sincerely hate what i do
and want to find ways to undermine my
positions i may have any positions i may
have those who agree or disagree with me
politically and those who are die hard
by attainers
and value my approach regardless of who
you are i appreciate you for simply
clicking the like button
at one point to follow me having said
that let me also prepare you for a few
things in our relationship moving
forward
i'm very comfortable in my own skin i'm
very comfortable knowing
you may or may not be in my life five to
ten years from now i'm very comfortable
knowing at some point you will disagree
with my views
if you haven't already done so i'm very
comfortable knowing i don't walk on what
i'm very comfortable knowing i don't
have all the answers
i am very comfortable knowing i'm
extremely confident
in my ability to reason any topic as
long as i put in the right amount of
researching i'm very comfortable knowing
that just like the iphone ios system
keeps upgrading and fixing new bugs i'll
be doing the same as well i'm very
comfortable knowing most people in the
world
lack the ability to reason logically and
stay
instead most reason emotionally i'm okay
with that i'm very comfortable knowing
that god gave me the life that he gave
me for a reason
i'm committed to being one of the best
soldiers this generation has ever seen
i'm very comfortable knowing that
some of my strong views will face
opposition and last but not least if you
think my content lately has been too
much for you
for some of you i plan on doubling down
very soon we're just getting warmed up
so
if that's not something you'd like to
see i suggest you unfollow me now
move on however if you value someone
who's authentic transparent and tells it
like it is they may want to stick around
i have zero plans to just shut up and
dribble i'm not going away either way
i'm genuinely thankful for you
and wish you nothing but the very best
love you
pbd that's what i said love you love you
pbd
sunday night 11 30 and i got a lot of
messages
from this year text messages instagram
stories from all over the world so what
inspired this all i want to say this
before we wrap up i got a pot i got a
zoom that people are waiting for me for
it's very simple
i'm in the game of recreating myself and
i do it every three to six months
every time you recreate yourself the old
group who was used to the same old same
old you doesn't like you because you're
getting better
it's a little bit uncomfortable we're
not changing we're going to get better
in the next
12 24 36 60 months we have
some very big surprises that you will
find out about very soon i cannot
wait to reveal these surprises for you
but all i can tell you is
if you like a good story if you like
going on a wild ride
stick around we're about to do something
ridiculous
together that we'll be sharing with you
very soon